down by your feet foreign
I saw one over here
there's a two right there
I'll get a dynamic all right go ahead
and pick that one up
there's two right there
they've been here a little while should
do 300.
there's one to your right
yeah 300 yep yeah and
it was I think there's five total I saw
right here
foreign
I was just trying to
discreetly disappear
there's no orientation
zero five
I need to bag them separately don't rub
them together too much
keep from scarring them
[Music]
see if we can get one in each finger
this glove it's a new glove
hmm
there's two
three
and hold I'm lost
or
out here
sweating I don't know
and five
[Music]
okay
took me too long right
all right
uh
so when when autopsy is over
um
and then from there
so I'm not sure if it is scheduled for
today my guess
do you know Jeff on the autopsy not yet
I don't I can find out and let you know
I step outside and call and see if
they've already made fun of it yeah I'll
step outside so I would imagine
um about a half hour ago
starts Harvey Corner okay so that means
they are in the process
so and that they will come back home to
y'all tonight
so then from there you can um
yeah
some of the tests take longer as far as
any kind of Toxicology or
gun stuff anything like that that they
may be insensitive but because there are
two people it will take a little bit
longer
10 of them but there are other
technology
will take that release tonight
that will not affect your funeral
arrangements
yes
I almost step out and call and see if
you have an idea